the signing of the treaty of
accession by spain and
portugal to the european
union 30 years ago was an important step
because two nations that had
suffered from dictatorships for decades
joined the democratic community of
nations in europe although we chasing the
stooges as a group protest against
this way that the
parliament itself slows down the fact that we
ourselves push our own rights aside
the shoulder was
decided on the
basis of the rules of procedure the rules in management are clear
that if too many
applications have been made and that plans are overloaded with this
, he has the right
to refer back and he has  may he also
deserve our support
bamberg stop
the criminal salemi national
production
differentiated with all their
obligations dependencies and
shadows should fifa remind
more of the many-headed
monster of the greek mythology of the hydra with
jose  ph blatter she only
lost a head